citizens of the reject Nation it is John
and Andrew Gordon reunited once again to
finally at long last check out the Heath
Ledger Motion Picture musical event A
Knight's Tale Andrew are you excited I
am so excited we've been talking about
this for a very long time actually we
actually have this is not hyperbole we
have really been talking about this for
years I have been wanting to watch more
Heath Ledger films obviously I want to
react to them in front of you guys but
uh I'm really excited for this one I've
been told for so many years how amazing
this film is so I'm excited most
definitely will Lords and Ladies of the
reject Kingdom why don't you go ahead
leave a like on the video that lets us
know that we're doing okay and hey don't
forget to subscribe hit that
notification Bell and a big thank you to
the folks over at prepper for cutting
down these highlights it's a big help
it's it's a hard task and we appreciate
them very much also if you want to
support the channel and grab a little
bit of swagger Rooney in the process
come on over to the new and improved
reject nationshop.com we got tons of
great t-shirt designs and other things
over there and last but not least if you
want to get the full experience of A
Knight's Tale alongside Andrew and I see
everything that doesn't make these
reaction highlights grab your own copy
come on over to patreon.com the real
Rejects and sync up with us you can
enjoy the complete film with Andrew and
I we also got a whole bunch of other
stuff over there with reaction
highlights of watch along is included
it's a blast without further Ado Now
ladies and Gentlemen let's hop in to a
night's tip
in medieval times the Sporter Rose
embraced by a noble and peasant fans
alike though only noble knights could
compete the sport was jousting for one
of these nights and over the hill former
Champion it was the end but for his
peasant Squire Will I Am it was merely
the beginning should we open we have to
be in the list in two minutes two
minutes or forfeit oh
yeah looking like Tom Hanks a Castaway
I suppose I believe a year after Cast
Away stuff
k2so correct they need to do is not fall
off it's awesome we've won oh
he's dead yeah about that
we're minutes from Victory I haven't
eaten in three days none of us have what
we need to fetch a priest no he's not
done
wake up he's mostly dead sir actor must
report it once or forfeit the match he's
on his way fortunately he wears a mask
so it's okay now or a helmet whatever
you I'll ride in his place
yes you will I'm asking you William
Thatcher to answer me with your name
that's a good name right there you have
to be of noble birth to compete a detail
if the Nobles find out who you are
they'll be the devil to pay and pray
that they don't
because I don't have enough money to pay
the devil
yes I'm loving the tone set right here
oh yeah this is the needle drops movie
isn't it that's like the one thing I've
heard is that there's gonna be crazy
music
away
Rock You
whenever I hear this song I think of the
Mighty Ducks
how little sport has changed Rufus siwa
nice and Paul Bettany Jarvis that's
right he's gonna be inside the uh helmet
you know tell William what to do that'd
be amazing
the score stands at three lances to none
in favor of Sir ekta Lord Philip of
Aragon stand you're ready look at the
actor he needs three points to beat you
so a broken Lance won't win it for him
he has to knock you off the hall I know
how to score Robin I've waited my whole
life for this moment your whole life I
selected he shot himself to death
what happened sir Hector
dysentery
[Music]
be right in the mug yeah but is he still
on the horse yeah
[Applause]
best two out of three
oops
oh a center of the peacock funny
no then
15. damn
never haggled with anybody before five
for Roland who's going straight home to
England straight to the pub for me your
pie the pub that's where I would go we
could do this we've done it by that
silver in your hand we can be champions
We are the champions my friends that's
13 for training and outfitting now the
tournament in rwan is in a month from
now in one month we could split a price
bigger than this one in one month we
could be laid in a ditch with selector I
don't want glorian riches William I just
want to go home candy cakes with
peppermint cream he's gonna say he's
like what about the pub what about my
eel pies name a man bet with the sword
than I in the practice ring you know of
noble wow and I won't spend the rest of
my life as nothing that is nothing and
nothing is right where glorial taken
what's that nothing it's food for the
crows if you can take your coins go to
England eat cake but if you can't you
come with me do some coin magic that was
quite the speech but I'm eating cake you
see money doesn't matter yeah
I'm with you buddy 13 silver pieces
three men can change their Stars we'll
all have new zodiac signs by morning God
love you William I know I know no one
else will
ah I like these guys
okay
there you go you at least make contact
yeah some contacts better than no
contact
oh
oh dozens of times I guess that means we
should do it again practice makes
perfect I disagree perfect practice
makes perfect practice makes Improvement
whoa that's cool
[Laughter]
that was worth it for all of that
gotta give it to him man Heath Ledger
really does have it yeah there's
something magnetic about the guy
is that Paul Bettany I recognize those
cheeks anywhere
whoa
what are you doing charging
good vocab were you robbed yes and then
at the same time a huge resounding no
it's more a sort of involuntary vow of
poverty
okay in pav Jeffrey choice is the name
oh [__]
Canterbury Tales up in here the writer
for a penny I'll scribbly anything you
want from summonses decrees edex
warrants patents of nobility
a new gentlemen are well I am sir auric
uh Von Lichtenstein from goldiland and
these here are my faithful Squires
delves and uh foul Hurst I'm Richard the
lionheart pleased to meet you
no wait a minute I'm Charlemagne no I'm
sitting on the bus ah
hold your tongue sir or lose it now you
see that I do believe
thank you
must be established for four generations
on either side of the family patents of
nobility must be provided in my services
oh and the road to ruin
a plus clothe me
shoot me for God's sake feed me Let Me
Ride That horse a bit and you'll have
your patents
try us and I will [__] you until your
insides are out and your outsides are in
your ring Trails will become your
x-trails bars
pain pain I would love to see that I
would love to see the outtakes of that
scene of Alan tutic 2 and then Paul
Bettany probably cracked up so many
times oh yeah man I must have been a fun
day on set son of gibbling son of
vendish the fourth Earl of Brunswick the
same vendish who inherited the fife of
Bloomberg Purdue Heralds six Generations
is more than enough like sir who are you
you're wearing clothes we don't
recognize you Roger lewd Mortimer thank
you very much
it's really good they uh met him on the
way over here yeah I just wish they left
him naked you know it's more than one
way to wheel the Lance I know one person
who would have appreciated that as an
audience member Jennifer Conley I didn't
think we had a chance
oh what what is it was your dark history
I passed along the River Thames it was
there I met a pretty lass she said her
name was Mel speak of the devil
how can you look at Heath and not smile
that's incredible
that
he fell for her
that's a fun shot
really enjoying the the energy of this
movie so yeah oh definitely the tone and
the energy for sure and the music of
course of course well I would hear you
speak if it cost me my ears that is well
but I do not want silence in my life hey
would you care if I were ugly well yes
love me if I was down and out you
desecrate the house of God
oh
yeah your blasphemy is amusing and
endearingly cute
call me a fox for that is all I am to
you foxy lady I just I only laugh just
to keep from weeping
because he is such a curse yes of course
I can swiftly pray your beauty Fades
that you may better serve God
say that to myself every morning why God
did you curse me with this face
God's Will has a purpose but
may not know it
[Music]
I've seen this guy in a bunch of stuff
that is lovely familiar
[Music]
Devil's wenches are going to hell well
Rick Von Liechtenstein yes I'm Simon the
Summoner and I'm overdue with the sword
Arena
I must attain you on behalf of your
Herald ah damn it you were never robbed
were you I'm just a nudist I have a
gambling problem
yeah people they'll quite literally take
the clothes off your back
how much does he owe you
Ten Gold florins
naked
all the betony butt shots man yeah all
right release him but God said give him
back his clothes and you'll get it you
better start winning
[__]
excuse me too late he's been enough
oh my God jeez
e
[Music]
God that armor looks so heavy yeah
seems like it would be kind of painful
on your joints too if plates moving
around
whoa dang
that's like what many strikes of that
was at least a couple
[Applause]
well done man
blown far from his homeland in search of
Glory and Honor we walk in the garden of
his turbulence The Garden of his
turbulence
[Applause]
killing it
the soundtrack is so fire
yeah and it's like you know at least
watching it at this point in time these
are all songs that have been around so
long that like even though they're you
know popular music contemporary music
they still feel a little timeless
yeah buddy
[Music]
you're gonna actually kill this guy
do it
do you want to touch it
oh God it looks so painful yeah
Whiplash alone Jesus
excuse me don't work for free and I
chant jealous with broken armor problem
not mine
just drop it a sweat has a price on it
welcome to capitalism buddy well just as
well they told me I was after even
asking who yeah oh the other armors I
love reverse psychology did they say I
couldn't do it because I'm a woman no I
don't care for it that much they said
you were great with horseshoes but shape
with armor the fact that you're a woman
wasn't even mentioned
they were woke in their discrimination
that was smart I will win this
tournament for you
[Music]
now I will I will win for you one of the
just in front and high champion at Saint
Emilio Rufus seawell oh a match it's
three Lancers one point is awarded for
breaking a lance on a man between the
waist and neck two points for breaking
on the helmet and three points for
bearing a rider to the ground oh damn
talking to her to the audience
yes I still need to hear it or perhaps
angels have no names yeah only beautiful
faces and you are your worst nightmare
Bon Liechtenstein from gelderland your
armor sir how stylish of you to joust in
an antique and start a new fashion if
you win my grandfather will be able to
wear his in public again retro man's
coming back it is with honor I
thank you not quite Benedict Cumberbatch
my ladies and everybody else here not
sitting on a cushion
plebes today you find yourselves equals
that's what I'm talking about how dare
he call us equals class is an illusion a
night
by nights
I first met him Atop A Mountain near
Jerusalem yeah
praying for God
when he saved a fatherless Beauty from
the Woodbury ravishings of her Dreadful
Turkish Uncle oh my
oh my just come up with this on the spot
oh yeah
Sterling improv right here yes and
that's
that's Serenity the protector of Italian
virginity
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
I love that name so much that was uh it
was quite a monologue monologue yeah I
would kill to be hailed half as
wonderfully as that for anything ever
one day I will hail you with a monologue
it's oh decent is that I'm honored
Andrew 13 gold pieces to you yes Yes
master valhurst I'm well aware a good
thonging is on the way
I will fund you this is some kind of
medieval torture
oh
[Applause]
it's like in glad you're just getting
the people on his side yeah are you not
to detained
oh God man every time
feel the impact split in a helmet's
visor is narrow but splinters can
penetrate it most Knights raise their
chins at the last instant you lose sight
of your opponent but you protect your
eyes yeah
I've never not finished before I wish to
keep my honor intact oh I promise Rufus
siwa like he picked up on a weakness
that he never takes his eye off the
target he's probably gonna use that
against him in their final battle
Yeah I'm also worried that this guy is
not being above board right now
oh okay
a draw and Cobble is hurt okay
maintaining the honor not bad why didn't
Ulrich finish him
he's a man of Honor
unlike you what an idiot then he shows
his weakness yeah go go back to COBRA
Kai man you're gonna say go back to dark
city and dark city you know everywhere
Rufus Sewells are found oh dark City's
cool oh I gotta see it I've seen the
trailer like a million times but not the
movie
women weaken their heart
it's big you soft bro you cannot win
okay concentrate angry cakes
Adam wire sense word he said he will win
this tournament for you he wins them for
himself and for his own honor so it's
nothing to say wins them for me yeah how
many of these jousting grams do you get
in a day
we have
Windows tournament for you
and he is the only Knight that has not
promised to do so I would have him win
my
heart reverse psychology is working I'm
loving this so far man yeah I gotta say
it's fun it's so Breezy but like the
cast is great the characters are so fun
and likable my lady [__] you were just
talking
of course my man she also said to tell
you her name
is Jocelyn oh
lovely
whoa that's cool that was quite a quite
a shot there is he already facing Rufus
oh yeah he is I guess round one fight
yeah well I guess this is his uh not to
get meta but his uh versus Bane the back
break that's right there's no way he's
gonna beat him your spirits are your
buddy
[Music]
like a fist on it yeah yeah bump it
I can't breathe what oh
bump it
oh
not bad not bad
huh solid if you're gonna get him in the
eyes though I'm not liking where this is
I'm not like in the tone shift right now
hey go try and blind him I believe
that's what happened in what a kid in
King Arthur's Court blinded Daniel Craig
art Malik whoa Daniel Craig is in a kid
in King Arthur's he is he is
so is Kate Winslet
yeah he went for the eyes whoa Dewey Cox
needs to think about his entire life
before he jousts
whole life flashing before his eyes
right now yeah someday I'll be a knight
a bunch of sun a knight you might as
well try to change the Stars
can a man change the Stars he believes
enough a man can do anything
good dad
oh goodness
oh oh
dude the lady
I believe this is yours
ugh
yeah thanks you have been weighed you
have been measured and you have been
found wanting
smells like a challenge I won't compete
in the sword again it's the best event
no it's Tournament champion or nothing
at all All or Nothing
10 Florence that should do yeah melt it
down I could make such armor you
wouldn't even know you wore it how much
would that cost me just take me as far
as Paris we travel alone take a golden
go oh come on dude my lady would know
the color of your Lord's tunic tonight
so that she can dress too much him ah
regret to inform your lady that we won't
actually be attendant oh do not answer
questions you don't know the answer too
green
all done
um
trimmed in a kind of Pale
green
wooden toggles
gonna be an interesting wardrobe change
oh this is a disaster all right your
tunic up quite nicely give us your
jacket what that's not a disaster Roland
I don't know how to dance
okay you just need a little liquid
courage my friend you run out of joust
in a month you can uh figure out how to
dance in a day
the second time we've seen someone with
something up their nose
oh and you can do better can you oh of
course again
I was wondering if you would care to
show us how to dance please please por
favor and one and two three
um is that the pinky swear dance yep I
could ask God one thing be to stop them
Beauty I'd asked him to stop the world
and melt with you show us a dance of
gelderland
you should have a dance off yeah
well you should bow
um
I wonder how much this was Improv
oh she does I think she's gotta know
that he's not of true Royal lineage
[Music]
production values in this are really
nice as well oh yeah like this is a
full-fledged period almost as good as
Role Models certainly let's do this we
shall
oh here we go
[Music]
I was gonna say it's been a long time
since we had a Neil drop people led me
to believe that that was like the main
thing about this movie was it's just all
needle drops this is just like song
three I just realized he was in dark
city with Jennifer Conley now he's in
Paul Bettany
the married couple so many layers of uh
Degrees of Separation so many degrees of
Kevin Bacon yeah twist Bend feel the
movement well I but eventually I will be
struck and then death do you at least
have the courage to test it
oh yeah let's do this
I didn't feel a thing she's his lucious
Fox
I'm just going off on all these dark
knight okay finished type in your name
[Applause]
drips in this movie man I love the sound
design yeah
my deepest honor to present to you I
can't unsee the Benedict Cumberbatch
yeah oh is this the guy who uh they he
forfeited because he was yeah yeah it's
the guy from before Oh I'm worried
something bad's gonna happen oh is he
forfeiting again how am I withdrew Adam
draw like that can mean only one thing
royalty wait what what happened is this
gonna buy him some kind of Allegiance
Colville is Edward the black prince of
Wales and Future King of England oh
[Music]
my man's wants a real challenge
what
get at it yeah
yes I like this guy
[Music]
oh my God
it's okay it's gonna be good for you in
the long run
and you also Prince Edward
[Music]
cool still you wrote it's not in me to
withdraw no me that's awesome respect
around my kingdom flower is only as good
as its petals too don't you think a
flower is good for nothing ouch dude a
flower doesn't keep you warm and a rose
never knocked a man off a horse either
you're just a silly girl oh no better a
silly girl with a flower than a silly
boy with a horse and a stick
true no
go to her called along hello hello
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa whoa
damn Adam has been called back to the
free companies black prince commanded it
could be gone all season first Joslin
and now Adam there's Mischief of a foot
I need to write a letter dear Jocelyn my
dearest Joseph was that wrong well it's
up to you really um it's your funeral
say something about her breast yeah you
miss a breast oh my goodness yeah let's
get some bosom bars going I haven't seen
you since a month I have seen the new
moon I have seen sunsets and sunrises
but nothing of your beautiful face put
me out of a gig I used to know this girl
once who well she broke my heart but I
used to say that the pieces of My Broken
Heart are so small that they could be
passed through the eye of a needle oh I
miss her like the sun misses the flower
I miss you like the sun misses the
flower love this team effort oh hates me
that is what gets me through the day and
especially the night the hope that after
you're gone from my sight it will not be
the last time I look upon you oh
you better frame this letter with all
the love that I possess
William oh yeah
yeah
he knew this is coming she's coming to
Paris
did you give me a token
she did
yeah he's got such an infectious smile
come on give it to me
yeah yeah
yeah
I could write full time and a forage for
me French wine is too much for English
bellies
what about this call me close tonight I
swear
I'm gonna start using that word from now
on bong to make that trip a hundred
times and most importantly because the
pump himself is French oh God is on
their side well the pope may be French
but Jesus is English you're on
yes he is
I love how that group has they've added
land killed our land
this is great sets and locations too
hey man cleanliness is Godliness you
know your favorite cathedrals I come for
confession
gonna confess who he is not now but soon
speak to me
speak those words I loved they're
playing this just all in the wide but
this tournament I'll win it in your name
every night I defeat I defeat for you
your beauty will be reflected in the
power of my arm that's not what you
wrote now you're just like all the
others I wish to hear poetry Ulrich oh
not ready
you could get in the zone I am and why
must everything for a woman be run on a
man's schedule that's how the world is
meant to work and I want it now your
breast day by day oh my god dude Day by
day's turn no no dude day by day now may
I prove my love to you poetry how I love
that we're staying in a white shot this
whole time I want you to act against
your normal character and do badly do
badly lose oh no except that I'm a loser
wrong losing is a much Keener test of
your life
sure oh my God and losing would show
your obedience to your lover and not to
yourself really great blocking in the
scene I will not
it's the last hurdle then you do not
love me
[Music]
rocking a hard place boy
I'm curious how many times he lost his
voice doing his monologues yeah
sure you are
I wonder if that was improved or not
[Applause]
losing I don't understand oh neither do
I
ah yes you do your heart does
Jonathan told me I should lose to prove
my love
oh God I'd rather you were blind
well then why in the name of Saint
sweetheart we're doing this for love man
the heart matters of the heart because I
love her
You Got It Bad man we're gonna lose so
much money
[Music]
he really loves her taking abuse
physical abuse they're just like
standing right next to him as all this
happens not even clear in the field and
your love
have you proven that yeah
she says that if you love her you will
not lose another match yes I don't have
to take more abuse
[Laughter]
[Music]
now that I've made it as difficult as
possible
yeah
yeah do it
oh damn dude that was sick yeah get a
little rail slide in there too that was
a little Tony right here yeah Tony Hawk
action there get some extra points for
that
[Applause]
ah dang we've got a souvenir here
we missed you at banquet sir oh Rick hi
Jocelyn me myself and I missed you your
prize I am not worthy of a prize my maid
tells me that sometimes you're Violet
and I call you William
here we go
Rick yes it is soon
it's just a name at the end of the day
she's not concerned with the actual you
know
royalty hierarchy yeah your name makes
no mess exactly yeah just so long as
you're of Royal lineage
and I am your
look at all the marks on is that how you
was gonna say I know it does look you
made me take so much physical abuse
[Music]
lovely I gotta imagine uh I wasn't quite
expecting well I was on his way yeah how
long since any you've been back I've
only been gone six months two years
three years for my eyes five belongings
18 years 18 years 12 years he's just
been a pretty state
how long for seven years oh is this
where like he grew up it's gonna be
where he gets separated from his uh
director I'm the Thatcher is this the
boy
looks like the shirt Alan Tudyk was
wearing earlier you afraid of me boy
it's afraid of [__] show me your arm got
a strong arm
I work out twice a week yeah never skip
arm Day always Skip Leg Day I can show
you a great wide world full of Adventure
I can show you the world no come on say
goodbye to your father let's get started
oh no he's a real night William watch
and learn all you can damn dude this
site is so supportive yeah you're a man
now
oh now go change your stars and live a
better life than I am oh I'm afraid I've
watched I won't know the way back home
don't be foolish William you just follow
your feet
huh that's a good line The Boys Are Back
in Town
soundtrack is so good in this movie
a lot of classic jams
regular Ted lasso over here
oh I knew they were gonna transition
back themselves I had a feeling yeah
that's a good transition I like that
Adamas here is entered yeah whatever
they're fighting no no the black prince
he was forcing to spawn his army yeah
pillaging town after town robbing and
murdering and
see Jesus as I promised you before Adamo
you would look up at me from the flat of
your back you will look up and shout
save us and I will whisper no beautiful
isn't she a real Thoroughbred trophy you
speak of chosen like she is a target
isn't she yeah trying to put my Lance in
it you know what I mean I've entered
into negotiations with her father yeah
ugh time to make her my bride
[Applause]
come on man let's do this thing
looks like the guy was already falling
kind of leaning well he said that thing
about you know like they'll lean back to
protect their eyes yeah yeah
I always sat on you oh
I was born in cheapside just around the
corner there well how old are you nine
and one half oh
I wonder if you remember a man they may
have died before you were born it was as
tall as a knight that's my dad
I remember him you do well yeah he lives
there still
oh
sometimes we see him sitting out the
window waiting for a son yeah
he's watching the Stars seeing if
they're gonna move
blind sir duh oh
damn someone there if you're here for
the net I haven't finished yet come back
tomorrow we'll tell them do not leave
without saying a word who are you come
on
my name is Ulrich I hear that name being
Enchanted from the stadium
[Music]
word of your son
yes oh
very well he wanted you to know
he changed his Stars after all oh
God this guy
has he followed his feet oh about his
way home
found his way home at last
yes
oh
please nobody oversee this
oh what a lovely moment that was great
that was beautiful oh but this leak
won't do father not in the chamber of a
thatcher
flying Factory is quite fitting
we'll fix it for you
oh I know damn it man God you are so
annoying
it's okay even if the truth is revealed
it'll destroy the class system improve
once and for all that anyone from any
humble beginning can rise the ranks if
they so choose to commit
I remember
Jeff that's the truth this day just gets
better yep yes it does and it's going to
keep doing that adamar
I told you last night
he says he saw your father yeah he asked
me for your patents they're waiting for
you in the lists they're going to arrest
you ah are you forfeit they've already
marked it down settle the horses make
the rest of your baggage not you what do
you think
now that you know what I am not to know
what you are William would take a
lifetime
sure one I am most willing to give but
right now you've got to run I like that
they didn't turn this into a
melodramatic conflict I love you
you and I'm sorry but I won't see you
led away Bound for the stocks oh but you
will see me run no
damn your pride William lose for me one
more time and where will we live in my
hovel with the pigs inside in winter so
they won't freeze yes William with the
pigs
oh Josephine you speak of what you do
not know
dude she's in like an arranged Contract
Marriage Ron William
oh
oh all good things must come to an end
attend them together it's been an honor
playing with you serving with you
okay I love this group yeah it's such a
great Ensemble like like I'm glad that
this movie is its own you know piece but
at the same time I'm like I would just
watch like a bunch of movies about these
guys yeah for sure I am here to compete
you are here to be arrested get up on
your horse bro
ah jeez dude you have been measured
big man
it's like come on hit me
with
let's start with the head the victim
gets all fuzzy in what world
you have ever beaten me you know the
real one out there when I'm not bound
yeah you're a sniveler you know it
I mean like you know it's a very
hateable character but he's doing a good
job
I like the notes in his performance too
subtle like ticks in his face let them
have me
God love you William
so do I hey someone else will
[Applause]
to the pain
dude I want to see her throw down with
the you know with the blacksmith hammers
[Applause]
oh I guess they're gonna pull a Bill and
Ted and come break them out yeah
we're pretending not to be one
pretending to be
also respects them yeah two sides of the
coin where is Harvey Dent you men love
you if I knew nothing else about you
that would be enough true that's also
tilt when you should withdraw and that
is nightly too more of a night than half
these guys man release him
release the Kraken but my personal
historians have discovered that he is
descendant from an ancient wow
if I may repay the kindness you once
showed me
my liege
oh you shall be knighted sir
by the power vested in me by my father
King Edward and by all the witnesses
here you are now an Avenger I dubbed
thee
Sir William
with his own name beautiful
are you sure
yeah it's nothing
but SpongeBob
what oh is he cheating
you
ah
dude
[Applause]
oh man you're on your own maybe she went
to get his dad maybe yeah
to the pain
you just have like a million of those
little fist covers yeah seriously
he's never been divorced
come on
oh
nice POV nice POV
that's not good
ah
oh
oh no cut me Mick
son of a [__] I know it's futile to ask
but are there like rules is there a ref
somewhere he is so freaking cheap we are
in cheap side after all yeah good point
if he gets hit again then he has to
knock him off his horse yeah he's gotta
knock him down I bet it's gonna come to
that
get him in the heart boy oh no oh [__]
[Music]
ah as I said in what well could you have
ever beaten me such a place does not
exist ah you just created it man clearly
this guy never saw one of A Knight's
Tale and so is your father oh yeah
yes oh I knew it I knew it this movie's
gonna make me cry you must enforce him
or kill him the only way to win kill him
that's like 10 points he's gonna say if
she wasn't getting his father I would
have no idea where she was no
leave it off
uh oh my she knows what he's doing I can
barely grip it
left hand flash it to my own
what Funk me
School band is here as long as they're
Kinder than the school band from
Halloween kills
I mean excuse me
oh yeah dude
that's right rally face like this
who rat and sheep and with heavy-handed
words it's Times Like These we learn to
live again I'm
[Applause]
and here before you now
[Music]
I don't think any movies maybe clap as
much as this yeah
this is like an event film
I mean Heath Ledger's got such eyes of
determination oh yeah man it's just
something you cannot teach he's crapping
in that tin can over there he knows this
guy has all the determination
come on boy
come on
is there some cinematic shots I love it
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
come on get off that horse yeah
oh
you like
impaled you have been weighed
I don't want it you have been measured
yes and you absolutely
have been found wanting
welcome to the new world yes
oh what a lovely shot too that is great
God this movie has so much life man
[Music]
[Applause]
oh what a cool like oh yeah it's like a
fantasy cutaway almost yeah yeah that
was so cool though I loved it
damn the courage to do that with no
armor that was live or die beautiful man
oh ho didn't need his eyesight for it he
just needed his ears ah man he could
feel the energy in the Crowd Oh wow he's
gained his or so I love that
seriously that goes a long way little
characters like that when you gain
respect seriously I love both the
details like that no like this movie
across the board yeah I know it's great
it's doing so much like you know for
years yeah slacking on my dad is for
years always talked about how much he
adores this film he actually had this on
a few months ago I'm like turn it off
John and I are watching this later it's
not a sacred movie yeah
love for prevails yes hey Nani ho
oh
the different film stock right here yeah
they definitely changed it
oh the stars have moved it's an effect
shot
that was great oh how lovely dude that
was so well done yes oh my goodness
who was uh the prince
oh play the prince Colville James
fearfoy okay yeah yeah yeah what has he
been in for he's been I couldn't name
him off the top of my head but he's a
definitely a name I've Seen A Face I
know I've seen a bunch of times
oh man you know like this movie I've
yeah same I've been hearing people talk
about for so much of my life and I
remember back in oh God what was it like
elementary junior high or whatever like
people fawning over Heath Ledger yeah
and uh and you know I haven't seen all
of the sort of main works that I think
people associate with him especially
from his you know heartthrob days things
like this or 10 Things I Hate About You
um and and yeah like he's so freaking
Charming he really is but beyond that
like I was really pleasantly surprised
and impressed by this not that I didn't
expect to enjoy it I certainly did but
you know like from the outside you know
the main thing I'd heard is like oh yeah
you know it's this fun sort of Night
movie that has you know kind of a fun
semi-comedic tone and a whole bunch of
anachronistic needle drops and funny
enough like yeah there are some needle
drops in this movie but it's not like
about that and it's not like throwing
you a new song every five seconds like
this managed I think in a really nice
way and in a way that is aged really
well to yeah utilize a few more modern
sensibilities and accoutrements but also
like really commit to bringing this time
period This World this you know
series of competitions to life with such
care and craftsmanship like again people
talk about I'm sorry we got the song you
won
I'm so sorry I'm sorry to interrupt I'm
sorry continue I just wanted to point
out we've got your song I'm sorry
continue
um no but like this is uh this is an
interesting movie to me because uh yeah
this is one of those where
um uh oh God I think I lost my train I'm
so sorry it's all good I'm so sorry no I
mean it's it's the classic yeah you know
uh uh Queen you know uh sporting event
song along with We Will Rock You Yes
um but yeah like this is one of those
movies that pleasantly surprised me and
people talk about how you know you can't
make you could never make certain things
today and usually when people say that I
think they're talking about stuff like
ablazing saddles or something like
definitely not actually I disagree I
think you could make Blazing Saddles
today I think it just depends on how you
pitch the satire and who is delivering
the Saturn yeah you know I I don't think
it's as impossible as people think and I
think actually it's more possible than
people think because we love edginess we
love pushing those boundaries and we do
love satire to me this is the kind of
movie where not that you couldn't make
it today but this is the kind of movie
that I don't think would get made today
because I feel like this is a swing and
you have to have you know a team that is
confident in what this is and how to
bring it to life but this is so many
things tied together you know it's a
Charming romantic comedy but it's also
uh you know a medieval you know night
tale as is you know indicated by the
title but it's also you know like a
buddy movie in a lot of ways and you
know it's got elements of you know
Shakespearean and certainly you know
chauth Syrian you know like classic
literature and things like that and it's
all rolled into one in such a unique way
that I'm like this seems like it would
be hard hard to pitch and get somebody
to put the money into oh another scene
headed to the pub
yeah
uh
yes ma'am
come on boy
I think I just shot myself
okay I'm glad we got that after they
were setting up a sequel there because
you know nowadays you know if you go
back this far one was this may 2011
you're like you know you go back to
older movies you're like oh my god there
was a post credit scene to us
I love right away too at the offset of
the film the tone they set with the we
will rock you and then the crowd is just
so into it but yeah yeah and I'd love to
it's I mean yeah Heath Ledger is
obviously the main character and he's
again his infectious smile and his charm
and God I miss him so much
um he's he's so fantastic in this role
he's fantastic in everything he did uh
but and I was so invested in his
character but it was such an ensemble
piece as well like that I love how we
started with the three of them which I
was already so invested in them right
when we started with them yeah but I
love that the the uh the it kind of just
crew with uh you know with Paul Bettany
and then with Kate and I just love the
way they interact with each other and
the way they work together like they're
just they're so perfect together the
five of them yeah I was just again I
just I loved all their interactions and
the way they work off of each other and
with each other and uh that scene too
and and this movie was
um a lot deeper than I was expecting
especially the whole uh oh no that's who
that actor was oh my God the dad John
Thatcher sure that was uh the actor did
you ever see three men and uh um a baby
no the sequel three the sequel three men
and a little lady that's uh that's the
uh I believe it's Edward uh he's the the
antagonist of the film uh because we're
not gonna call him evil even though he
was not a nice man in that film but I
was like I know this actor looks so
familiar my God
that's why I was killing me all moving
like who is this actor yeah he's he's
great oh God Rest his soul so sad he
passed as well yeah I mean um there's so
many great character actors across this
from the main Ensemble oh you also got
Shannon saw someone Laura Fraser yes um
and you know Mark Addy I know I've seen
him stuff yeah I think he was also Fred
Flintstone and Vivo rock viva I think I
think that's who he was I bet you're
right
um but uh yeah no again I I just I love
the oh yeah he was the director of
payback okay so I wasn't there you go so
I like that he worked with Mel Gibson
then the very next year Mel Gibson
worked with Heath Ledger and Patriot and
the very next year he worked with uh
it's you're six degrees there you go
um but yeah no this this film was really
a fun time and I like that they mix so
many different genres you know you got
the medieval stuff you got the comedic
stuff and then you have a kick-ass
soundtrack
um and I love all the stunts too and all
the choreography with all the was it the
jousting yeah that was all so well done
I mean I really was on the edge of my
see when all that was happening there
was a lot of suspense and that obviously
you know like most of the time he's he's
going to be okay but still because I'm
so invested in the characters I still
felt a sense of suspense and all that
and I really love uh the character just
from the backstory that we got and that
he wanted to be he just had this dream
of being a knight and I loved all the
obstacles he had to go through and
that's something I can relate to and I
feel like most of us can't just dealing
with obstacles and difficulties and you
know stuff like that and that's
something transcending the station it
feels like Society is mandating to you
yeah you know and certainly there's that
classic element that so much uh classic
literature and stuff like that explores
of you know defying class and these
ideas that like yeah the common person
can marry for love and you know this
game of riches and royalty comes with
the burden of so many things being taken
out of your hands in control yeah and
and I think that too like this this was
really lovely in the sense that it felt
like a classic sort of Hollywood movie
in that it's fully committed to
everything it's trying to do it's not
taking a pass on like you know they
really threw down on the stunts on the
jousting even the sword fighting uh in
ways where you're like yeah you could
have you know skimped out on this and
just focused on ah it's a romantic
comedy but I like that yeah they they
committed to every portion of this so it
does feel a bit like a bit more
substantial or a bit like something more
Shakespearean or again just like classic
and literary and two what I really
appreciated is within some of those
classic archetypical plot beats and
stuff like that this made a nice balance
between certain things that you know are
gonna work out in one way or another
because you know it ties together nicely
this is a Hollywood movie but at the
same time I thought they made some key
choices
um that kept them from falling into too
many sort of like rote holes and things
like that like I like that
um Jocelyn and Kate didn't have to
become a love triangle Kate just becomes
part of the crew and I also like that
Jocelyn you know she kind of figures out
what the truth is about William and it's
not a big deal because the love is
what's important and I feel like you
know in a different movie we might have
had a whole part of the movie where it's
like oh All Is Lost she knows the truth
and she's so hurt and offended by this
yeah
um and I like that they chose not to do
things like that in favor of doing other
things making slightly more
sophisticated choices absolutely really
being yeah sort of playful and
compassionate while also Rowdy and
boisterous and uh and yeah I love the
stuff with Jocelyn I love the
development of their love I love the
stuff with the dad and the payoffs of
that like this felt sort of
all-encompassing of a sort of coming of
age for various characters uh on screen
here no I was not expecting to shed some
tears in this film and the stuff with
the dad definitely did I was so invested
in the love between Jocelyn and will as
well and yeah like I said this was
definitely a lot deeper than I was
expecting because I I really other than
hearing it was a kick-ass soundtrack it
was a lot of fun yeah I wasn't and there
was jousting involved I didn't really
know too much about this film yeah other
than it was a fun good time so I was
pleasantly surprised and like to your
point too you made some you know about
the uh that they didn't go the trophy uh
you know generic ways in terms of like
the love trial because when you pointed
that out with Kate I was like in my head
I'm like I really hope they don't go
that route I actually thought too I'm
hoping they don't go that and maybe Kate
is gonna fall for one of the other guys
in the uh in their Ensemble Group which
is fine that they didn't even do that
maybe she did I don't know one of the
guys yeah yeah she's just one of the
guys which is cool I mean I'm but I'm
glad they didn't do the love trial it
wasn't necessary and then
um uh that's another thing I was gonna
there was another thing I had lost my
train of thought but I'm glad that they
didn't go that route and again it's just
the film was really well balanced uh so
you know that they it wasn't just
focused on The Love Story there was the
jousting stuff there was the stuff with
uh his father and I really also thought
Rufus Seawall did a hell of a job like I
really hate it is scary characters so
much
um but he did a hell of a job I haven't
seen too many of his films other than
Legend of Zorro film I do not care for
um but he's he's a great actor I I still
need to see dark city but uh I thought
he gave a a really good performance uh
to the point again where I did not like
him in any way shape or form as rooting
against him obviously I don't agree with
this character I understand his
motivations and all that but um it's
that great balance of I I hate this guy
and I and it's all because the actor is
doing a terrific job committing to a
thankless role committing to a role that
you know it might be I could easily
imagine different ways in which like ah
you know I want to kind of redeem this
guy or I want to find a way in my own
way to make kind of likable but here
yeah I thought he fully committed and
you need that you know I it takes I
think a lot to be able to fully commit
to being the anti-charm of the movie
yeah you know and two I I thought this
um you know had a really just Keen AI
for small details like you pointed out
with um uh I think it's the Scott handy
character like the um the Squire who's
always hailing uh Adam are you know like
even him coming around and just like
those little gross and Transitions and I
like that this too is like you're going
from tournament to tournament in so many
ways and like you cut out to like you
know them on the battlefield when uh
adamar is taken out of the games and
stuff like that but for the most part
it's it's contained to this side of the
world so it is like kind of like a
sports movie too totally and uh I also
thought that yeah again this was a movie
where for as light and Breezy and fun as
it is it also has a lot of really lovely
filmmaking flourishes not just in the
fact that they clearly threw down for
various locations and beautiful sets and
you know the costumes and everything
like that but also like the way they
shot a lot of this was really
interesting and it accentuated the
action but then you've also got scenes
like when they're talking in the church
I was just about to say that yeah
wide tracking shot that feels like
you're in a play for a minute and it's
like stuff like that is like you know
that's an inspired choice and there are
a lot of inspired choices I felt like
across this rather than just like
serviceable or you know workmen-like
choices and they stayed on that shot for
a good like minute or two I love how
they stayed in that wide shot for I mean
that is straight up filmmaking right
there and there were some really
cinematic shots to Epic cinematic shots
in terms of when they were doing the
jousting too so yeah I know the
cinematography in this film was really
inspiring for me personally but yeah I
know all in all good time and I gotta
tell you too before we end this uh I
loved pulpit and these monologues in
this film they were so damn good
I'd be hailed that way ever oh yeah I
got I can't I mean there were a couple
times too because he's yelling at the CR
I mean like obviously trying to you know
ramp up uh William and all that so but
he's because he's got to talk to the
crowd he's got to be loud yeah I'm kind
of curious if Paul pettini losses
because I know he must I know we've made
like 10 000 Dark Knight references
during this uh uh reaction uh and I know
for a fact that Christian Bale lost his
voice many times doing uh you know the
Batman voice I'm kind of curious if Paul
Bettany lost his voice at all doing
those La unless that's you know he's
going in the studio and doing uh you
know ADR and all that but uh I'm curious
if he did lose his voice but again in on
all the the ensemble cast was great but
Paul petney's monologues were everything
yeah in this movie they're so good I
wouldn't be surprised that last one or
one not last one but one of those ones
the one where he's standing on the rail
and he's like bellowing and almost kind
of slurring the words at the very and
he's like he says something to the
effect of like you know I'm I'm good you
know like or something yeah and that
felt like well it could have easily
could have been in the script but that
sort of felt like an off the cuff moment
of just like I've completed the
monologue and I was gonna throw this out
and uh and it fits the character so
we're gonna keep it I'm also curious too
like that armor that Heath and all the
other actors where I'm curious how heavy
that was in real life too sure it's got
to be yeah it's got to be rendered of
some kind of lighter material but even
so yeah like I loved all the different
helmet designs and all the different
armors we got to see like how much
training they had to do in real life I'm
sure there were obviously points where
there's stunt guys and all that stuff
too but I'm sure like you know there's
times too where the actors want to get
in there and get their Tom Cruise on and
like no I'm doing this myself yeah I
feel like you know if you're a history
nerd who is you know about this era of
uh of History uh I don't know if it's
accurate necessarily but I bet there's a
lot for you to kind of appreciate and to
get engrossed by or pause and sort of
pick apart and uh and yeah this is just
a true you know feat of craftsmanship
that was also so lovely and so fun and
so enjoyable and uh and yeah I I I love
this man yeah I truly did years in the
making of talking about and we finally
got to do and I'm so happy and it lived
up to the hype it did it with honor my
friends so uh yeah leave us your
thoughts on A Knight's Tale when did you
first see this uh what's your favorite
moment from the film let us know and
before we get out of here let's do a
quick patron of the day shout out to Sir
Andrew of house Hayes you are the person
at our patreon I would want to joust the
most my friend see you come from a
humble background you know of Locksmiths
you know you know a trade but you also
have a heart of gold and courage of a
lion and I feel like you know if I were
to meet you out on the battlefield I
would be maybe sort of taken aback like
I don't know man this guy may be short
of stature but he is 10 times taller in
heart and in hotzba and I would be
honored to be foisted from my Steed by
your powerful Lance my friends so uh
appreciate you uh keep your pledge to
the kingdom reject and and you will
always be welcome in these lands no
matter what your station's status or
otherwise be well buddy thank you so
much for being here you're one of our
oldest patrons and uh and yeah we will
never ask you know for your your lineage
papers because we know you've been here
and we got the evidence to prove it so
I'll bet and he's got nothing on you
that was quite a funking I like that
yeah we're just here to thong all night
long but anyway love you buddy thank you
all for tuning in and we'll catch you
for another flick keep an eye out peace
people
[Music]
[Applause]